- one and liftoff the rise of starlight
the Atlas rocket carrying the unmanned
Starliner capsule survived one of its
biggest challenges only to run into
problems minutes after liftoff it
appears as though the mission elapsed
timing system had an error in it and
that anomaly resulted in the vehicle
believing that the time was different
than it actually was NASA awarded
contracts to both Boeing and SpaceX the
company owned by billionaire Elon Musk
to develop cheaper reusable methods of
going to space NASA's astronauts have
been riding Russian Soyuz Rockets since
retiring the space shuttle fleet eight
years ago SpaceX successfully launched
its unmanned Dragon capsule into space
for the first time three months ago and
Boeing is hoping to send astronauts into
orbit next year from Boeing as likely as
a result of this to slip at least a
month or two I don't think it'll be a
huge huge delay these things happen in
Space Flight
you get delays all the time but it does
it raises the probability that America
will have to go to the Russians cut in
hand and buy some more seats on the
Russian Soyuz this latest hitch is more
bad news for Boeing it's already paid a
high price this year for two 737 max
crashes within five months killing 346
passengers and crew in Indonesia and
Ethiopia that calls the grounding of the
max fleet worldwide at the removal of
Boeing's chief executive and
multi-billion dollar losses to Boeing
share price and income and production of
the latest version of the world's
best-selling airliner was stopped
earlier this week
the difficulties of the American
aerospace industry giant are a reminder
that there's plenty of training and
learning ahead for Boeing before NASA
succeeds in the new space race getting
private companies to launch astronauts
into orbit in a new type of space taxi
Victoria Gaytan be aljazeera offer more
on this let's talk to Francisco Diego
he's a senior teaching fellow at the
Department of physics and astronomy at
University College London so Francisco
it seems that Starliner is now headed
back to earnest what went wrong I think
it's a very simple fault and it's
unbelievable that this thing happened
the space car has onboard a clock and
apparently the clock is controlling all
the operations in the in the spacecraft
he was launched very successfully and
then half an hour later he said
separated from the rocket that wouldn't
very well and it's supposed to take
control on its own movement and it has
to lift the orbit from what it was to
the orbit of the space station but it
didn't because the clock assumed that he
had already done so and then it was a
mismatch between the the timing of the
fighting the rockets that to lift it to
the to the Starliner rockets to lift it
to the space station and it never
happened it was real eyes on the ground
and by coincidence by five fatal
coincidence here they couldn't
communicate with the spacecraft because
it they communicate via relay satellites
and the space rock was in a kind of
death area but in a silent area between
the two satellites when humans were not
able to be sending time there and that
was finally they aborted the whole
linking today to the International Space
Station and the spacecraft is in orbit
right now around the earth in a lower
orbit and then he will land
apparently the idea is to land the
spacecraft in a couple of days somewhere
in the in New Mexico somewhere there
which will be also a very useful test of
course is not a completely failure but
we miss the opportunity to dock into the
space station so Francisco this was an
uncrewed
mission so no one know humans on board
if there had been astronauts on board
could they fix this the idea I mean what
we have from NASA is that had been any
astronauts on board they would have
taken control of the of the situation
and they would have succeeded in lifting
the orbit to the orbit of the space
station and the mission would have been
successful right I see Francisco that
this this um this module and the
competing SpaceX module both of them got
seed funding from NASA have we now seen
a shift that the space race is being
dominated by the private sector and
governments are stepping back and just
giving them money well it's not so much
so we have to remember that the big
capsule the Orion capsule that is going
to take astronauts beyond low Earth
orbit to Mars to the Moon and Mars is
being done by NASA but yes this I think
there is a lot of regulation to be
implemented in order to to bring all
these commercial partners into the play
specially we need this as we saw in your
reportage here to once we are talking
about launching asteroids and people
into space we have to be careful and the
regulations has to be very very strict
in this case which was a minor fault I
think it's not a major a major thing but
they say it makes you think that what
may happen in the future so Francisco by
my understanding these modules are meant
for both astronauts and commercial
passengers right sir
how soon could we see commercial
passengers in space Oh
commercial passengers I I think the the
this one this is the star liner and also
the SpaceX crew Dragon has have at least
one seat that it was supposed to be sold
to a space tourists I would expect to
not to see that in the in in less than
one year one year is not a very long
time Francisco Diego there the senior
teaching fellow at the Department of
physics and astronomy at University
College London thank you for joining us
on al-jazeera
it's a pleasure